There's no reason to risk a mans life here
Don't do this at home kids
Alright you ready?
are you ready?
3.
2.
1.
Action!
[SFX]Music by jhfly
[SFX]
Apparently we have some boxes full of large balls that you can put yourself inside of (ball x 1)
and then hit other balls with (ball x 2)
and its like a ball war (ball x 3)
lets see how big these balls really are (ball x 4) vig
[well edited unboxing]
It's a bubble ball! (ball x 5)
oh there's two of them in here
What kind of balls are those? (ball x 6)
battle
battle balls
battle balls(ball x 7)
(ball x 8)
(ball x 9)
So here we have a giant ball
So here we have a giant ball (ball x 10)
problem:
problem: it requires a lot of air to be inflated
solution:
question mark
air compressor maybe?
We'll find out
[air compressor noises]
I have a question about whether it's going to fit through the door
ah, shit
oh Jesus
real tight
we are almost there
one little thing at a time
dude it is like i am surrounded by carbon fiber
[laughing]
ah
what is th... where did this come from
wait we have more yea we have six
[Wren laughing]
here NIko
i'll getcha up
nooo!
it is not everyday you get to  just like push your bosses around
It shocked me
there is static, look at his hair it is static
[laughing]
look at your hair
you know sometimes it is like really hard to come  up with ideas for a videos and you got to like sit down and really hit your head against a  table several times before  you come up with something that is even decent
and then you got to rift on that untill it becomes a video idea
i was envisioning Clint as Gizmo Duck
riding a one-wheel
if your a kid born in the 90's you may have watched a TV show called DuckTales or Dark Wing Duck two excellent shows  i think they even remaking Duck Tales
it was a cartoon with a bunch of ducks as people
there was a character from that show who basically inherited what was essentially Iron Man armor
all the character wants to do is just save
people and be a hero but he's constantly
struggling to even use the suit he
wasn't the intended wearer of the suit
he accidentally said like the activation
phrase so the armor jumped on to him
where as like it was meant for this other
scientist who actually knows how to use
the suit but instead it's this bumbling
accountant he's like stop right there
I'm gonna fire missile at you no fires
like the opposite way
Gizmo Duck does not have legs he has a wheel for
feet he's pretty much my spirit animal
he has like this hit piece and out of it
stick like two springs like shock
absorbers in a really nice mountain bike
gizmo duck moves entirely by riding
this wheel and I was thinking about how
would I do that
so obviously the first thing is you
dressed up like is Gizmo Duck and you ride
around on the one wheel do you have this
issue and that you have legs you have legs?
I mean for now I have legs someday I
won't because i will be a few beta
bites on a hard drive someday my final
form is data
let's do filling up some big inflatable
balls alright now why do you need that thing
he's got enough lung power of those good
there's your video right there okay and
then finishing it you're passing out
that would be nice what would be really
nice is to get some really incredible
pot and smoke and then blow the pot air
into here so it's trapped no seriously
and it's to make a funny video take this
tool part everybody at the party would
you say a disc this is at least third
this is a thirty people hit oh my god ii
would be a wearable bong and listen this
idea is a million dollar idea a wearable
bong I'm telling you I've come up with
it I look fucking genius what was the
name of the doctor again what was it was
my character's name perfessor oak master Oh
more like professional toke yeah
Oh Oh on top of the fact I think the
character is really cool and sets up a
lot of like dramatic story beats it's
the fact that he's writing a freakin
wheel as cool as the one wheel is you
can't be gizmo duck and ride a one
wheel you have to be the one wheel the
warden rule so to do that there's a very
specific visual effects technique that I
would employ to make that happen and
that's essentially you paint out the
bottom half of the body and replace it
with a CG render of that contraption
I replaced the wheel are well what the
wheel delivers is realistic motion you
can't pretend to do this by like walking
around can you like I'm riding a one
riolu your heads gonna be bumping up the
couch you gotta be riding the one wheel
so I'll show you there's no reason to
risk a man's life here
I need to strap atleast around my arms or
else I think I'm gonna go flying you good yep
just a little bit just a little bit this
will give us the best look don't do this
at home kid just don't go back number
Bethlehem hark we'll look at my thighs
all right three two one actually fuck
you man fuck you I've been waiting to do
that for long
hey you we're back in action finally
celebrate we've decided to release a
brand new hat it's our name in katakana
which is really cool designed by the
talented kinder Tom we are releasing
this as of right now if you have missed
out on a chance to get a hat here's your
chance to get another one
it's an heather dark gray with yellow
print ooh check it out go to the store
and snag one because there's no time to
explain just just go there just quick
hit the button just hit the button hit the
button
[laughing]